do you have any favorite traditions like
for Christmas that you do with your
families or anything um yeah I do
it's it's a little offbeat off-centre
love but it's a tradition in our family
and I think it comes from their
traditions that they brought to America
from Peru um it's a little crazy so home
so what you do is you take you take a
napkin and you tuck it behind the person
who's playing that you tuck it in their
pants like a little tail I'll take a
little tail then you light it on fire
you play a song and they have to shake
their butt and and light like you know
put out the fire before the song is over
or else well before they for their pants
catch on fire
that leaves your score what is this is
this a tradition are they running from
sorry you escaping a spirit look what
it's all in fun spirit it's all fun yeah
it's not it's not menacing at all it's
like but basically if you don't know how
to sugar but you can't you can't you
know what do you have any ones that
might be you in ER I mean I'm Irish
Catholic so like guilt I guess
[Applause]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this